and I told her I said' look if you start
digging if you find out my name like
I'll leave like there's certain things
that catch you staying in contact with
people that you know that's how you get
caught you know going back to see people
that's how you get caught you know um
telling people who you are that's how
you get caught and I was like
so I'm Joseph
Carter everything's fine and she was
like okay you know and keep in mind too
this girl do you oh your car is broken
or your car's not doing well take it and
trade it in we'll go get you another car
we'll go get you you know an Infinity
you know FX or whatever you know a$
55,000 $60,000 vehicle she's
driving the equivalent of a a beat up
old Nova you know I mean it's you want
to go on vacation we'll go on vacation
you want to do this you want to do that
so you know we're buying houses I I'm
we're we're renovating houses we're
we're building brand new houses we're
buying Lots like she's like in the
middle of this like holy Jesus there's
hundreds of thousands of dollars in the
bank in our bank account uh her bank
account I open up a corporation in her
name she's opening up bank accounts
she's got web there's websites it's it's
a lot and while this is
happening we start seeing a a a friend
of hers so this other girl comes in the
picture her name's Trina and um Trina is
um semi- lesbian
so is is like a sexual thing or actual
relationship no it's no it's more like a
she's coming over a couple times a week
okay so we've got a ton of tons going
on uh
and put this so while this is happening
I I end up coming out in like several
magazines so I'm thinking thinking this
whole thing's dying down but it's not
dying down because now I just got caught
and handcuffed in a bank walked out of
the police station outran Marshals
although that that part the Marshall
thing never was never in the papers but
um the getting caught and handcuffed in
the bank when that hit the papers that's
everywhere bro that's huge you know
suddenly Chicago tribunes running a
series The fugitives um I'm in Bloomberg
business week they run an articles
article called you know sharks in the
housing pool uh then you've got a
Fortune Magazine comes out with a thing
because by now guess what Becky's been
caught oh Becky Becky Becky is she in
Houston or whatever in Houston got
caught and did she but gangster bro like
the way she here's the thing hey there
you go no oh no she told on me
immediately oh she did oh no it's fine
she do the right thing so here here's
what's funny about that I don't know
about that she here's what she says
loyalty is everything in this world my
friend that you and I disagree on I just
took off I just took off still on her
and left her with with with listen with
like six or like five or $600,000 is
what I left her with it's not it's not
all about money Matthew it's also about
just like you know ride or die there's a
meaning to that my God I'm sorry go
ahead she told she said everything well
here's what what when I say gangster
when she gets caught yeah um
they come in she's in the middle of
beauty school she's paid for beauty
school she's going through beauty school
she's gonna open like a salon or
something so she's in there cutting hair
in a class you know on a mannequin and
all of a sudden like five or six Secret
Service agents come in guns drawn
screaming get on the ground get on the
ground she said everybody dropped the
ground she said I'm sitting there with
scissors
going you know they grab her they
handcuff her they bring her in and the
whole time now at that point she was
Rebecca well she was
yeah her name was Rebecca hickey she
went by Becca she so she's Rebecca
hickey which is you know it's she's got
a Texas driver's license the whole thing
and they're screaming at her and they
she they put her in the car and they're
driving the whole way she go the guy the
secret service agent told me 45 minutes
she's telling us you're losing your job
bro you're losing I mean he he's like I
I couldn't believe it like we we got
pictures of her we're like this is you
she's like that's not me are you insane
look at that chubby little thing she
would not budge till they actually put
her hand on the scanner and she goes
okay I'm I'm Rebecca Hal what do you
need they're like where's Matt coock
she's I have no idea that [__] left me
like a year ago
so um so but she contributed to the
story to the legend that's already
growing oh oh because she was
interviewed by uh Fortune Magazine and
it was horrendous the article is
horrendous he was a abive he he's a Don
Juan that that forced me to fall in love
with him commit mortgage fraud and then
took all the money and left by the way
they found like 40 or 50 Grand on her
and maybe another 30 or 40 in her bank
account and no other
money yeah where's the other money um so
anyway and she was by the way she got
caught she was in communication with her
family was so she's talking to her mom
that's when she got caught ultim and her
mother through multiple conversations
one conversation being Mom I'm doing
fine um I can't tell you where I am you
know exactly but I I'm in Houston Texas
I'm fine next one six months later I
enrolled in Beauty School Houston Texas
Beauty School how many are there Y and
her mom
bipolar I just want to see my daughter
I'm going to call the Secret Service yep
I'm doing the right thing yeah and and
honestly she is doing the right thing so
um so you're getting more and more
famous nationally right so I've got all
these houses you you're you're having
threesome with Amanda and Trina and and
what ends up happening is we end up
going on you know and listen Amanda and
I we've gone on we've gone to Greece
Italy um Croatia um we're we're we've
gone we're going on multiple just
multiple trips and
we just gotten back from like a 10day
cruise of the Greek
Isles
and there's we get home and Amanda goes
online and there's a Blog about Date
Line about their one of their new
specials called the thief of
hearts and that's me apparently I'm the
thief of
hearts and I'm apparently going around
and I'm and it's it's BAS based on you
know Rebecca's you know Becky's story
that I'm wooing women to commit fraud
stealing all the money and then leaving
them to hold the bag
well they interviewed her they're
interviewing multiple people multiple in
my uh in my case they put together this
they're putting together an
episode going to be released in a few in
a month or so so I'm terrified I've at
this point I've been on the run three
years and I'm like I there's lots of
things I could care less about fortun I
don't know anybody that reads Fortune
Bloomberg come on I hang out with I'm
hanging out with contractors and
laborers and you know I'm not hanging
out with these guys so you know local
news who cares you know even even local
news channels you know I don't care but
dat line there weren't 400 channels back
then you know so Dateline comes out even
if you don't see it the first time
they're going to rerun it in three
months or six months or five year 10
years from now they might rerun it again
my face is going to be on it so I could
be perfectly fine five years from now in
one day I the Barista that I go to every
every other day look looks at dat line
and goes oh my God that's Mr Johnson or
that's Mr Thomas or whatever so the
point is is that I was like I got to go
I can't stay here I got to get out of
the country so I was going to go to um
well we really started doing research
and aanda ended up saying Australia
Australia at the time I don't know how
it is now but at the time if you went to
Australia with like like a
$100,000 and a business plan you could
become a permanent resident alien you
you you can't vote but you can buy
property you can open a business but you
can't get a job and they didn't require
a fingerprints so there's no criminal um
background check now if you wanted to be
a citizen you have to get an FBI
criminal background check like I no I'm
good so I was like wow wow I can go
there and start a business and I'm going
to start show up with a couple million
so what we do is we start refinancing
houses we start pulling out money as
quick as we
can I'm asking guys laborers guys that I
work with my general contractor my real
estate agent hey man can you cash this
check for six grand you C nobody says no
everybody yeah no problem no problem no
few guys like yeah man if you give me
10% yeah I'll give you 10% so that's
happening we're pulling out
cash um
um one
day Amanda gives Trina a bunch of checks
and asks her to cash them that Sparks a
conversation that like what it was
happening she confides
in by this point by the way Amanda knows
who I am MH so by this point she's
actually came across the letter that I
wrote to my parents when I left Tampa so
she's figured fig out who I
am she tells Trina his name's Matt Cox
dat Line's coming out we're going to
we're leaving we got to get a bunch of
cash and Trina goes okay I'll cash the
checks what she does instead is she
calls the Secret Service they watch my
house for three days I come home one
day they pull the cars
up and they arrest
me so you know it's a little bit longer
than that but that's shorter that's a
short version of me getting arrested and
you know I've probably skipped over so
simple because youve gotten the way with
much more complex
situations it's women man it's women uh
joking they also are the thing that make
life worthwhile listen God bless Trina
she did the right thing it honestly
based on there you go back to the right
thing but I mean based on what she saw
uhhuh based on what the Secret Service
told
her and what in the the articles that
she's reading I'm a bad guy I mean I'm a
bad guy in general right so I don't
deserve loyalty I I don't think so um
I'm ripping people off and she's
thinking that her friend is in
danger you know the FBI is saying I have
a weapon he's he's dangerous he's got a
weapon you know we believe he's armed
and dangerous when I was in Florida I
had a concealed weapons permit but I
gotten rid of both my guns when I was
placed on probation I've never had one
since I've never gun sense but they use
that to say you know they said oh he had
a concealed weapon for him okay well
then he's armed in dangerous like
there's these little things and think
they're telling her read this article
look he forces girls to fall in love
with them then he he that's what he's
going to do your friend so she
negotiated a also I think she got 10,000
I think which is embarrassing I'm I'm
ashamed that she she got
$10,000 and said everything yeah and and
told them this is where he is his name
is Joseph
Carter you know he's uh
you know this is where he is they watch
it they grab me they arrest me they
bring me
downtown you know what what did what did
you feel like when you got it didn't
feel good bro it was bad it was a bad
day it was a bad day first of
all casin Royale was coming out on
Friday yeah it was the first Daniel
Craig as James Bond yeah and the whole
week I'd been telling Amanda I'm going
to go see Casina Royale she' go well on
Saturday we're going to go to the
Festival I go that's fine but on Friday
castina and she's like right castina
Royale and she's like okay by the way on
Thursday I thought we could go to dinner
that's fine but on Friday cin Royale and
when they put the handcuffs on you
remember the first thing I thought of
I'm not going to [__] to see see
royal I'm not going to get to see it not
going to see it and I saw it about about
five six years later and when on the
institution's movie channel you know was
nice it's not the same but um yeah so I
they they bring me to Nashville then
they transport me to all over the place
I go on you know uh Conair they fly me
to
Oklahoma uh they fly me to
Atlanta then I I get go to Atlanta I'm
placed in the US Marshalls holdover uh I
get assigned an attorney go in front of
the
judge plead not guilty uh meet with my
attorney you always plead not guilty you
know whenever you they people say can
you believe that he plead not guilty
that's the first thing you nobody walks
in and pleads guilty you plead not
guilty while you kind of figure out what
you're going to do so I plead not guilty
there's no bond uh obviously I've got
they caught me when they caught me I had
four or five passports
so that's no good um they they charged
me with uh you know um bank fraud
conspirac commit bang fraud wire fraud
mail fraud um passport fraud conspiracy
or what was the other um aggravated
identity theft money laundering use of a
fraudulent
passport uh you know and there's like
there's there's like you know 30 counts
of this 20 counts of this 20 but none of
that matters like even if you just took
the dropped all the counts to one count
and stacked them it's like 150 something
years not so everything everything they
could and that's so they always say
you're looking at 150,000 you know your
lawyers they're like this you're not
looking at that you're looking at 54
years what that's no better that's no
better so uh yeah so uh my lawyer comes
in and sees me one day you know like our
first meeting and I she says you know
I'm uh Millie Millie
dun and she says uh listen I've looked
at everything for first they say you're
responsible for it's like 25 or 20 or 30
25 or 26 million in loss and I'm like
that's I've never that's not true that's
that's not true and I was like you know
not even I said not even potential law
there just no way I mean there no way
and then they come back she comes back
and she says well they're
saying 19 million now it's not possible
tell I I didn't no so when the the FBI
is saying like 40 million they're saying
11.5 in in Tampa plus 40 million for the
mortgage company so that it ends up
being like plus what I stole on the run
it ends up being like 55 million but she
gets them to drop like the 40 like
that's that's that's his Brokers that's
this that's that drop it and they're
like we he's so done it doesn't matter
they dropped that so it ends up it ends
up being like 15 million and then it's
down to what is he o they said 9.5 and I
got it down to like 6 million so you
know which you know I'm good for so uh
what ends up happening is they've
charged me with all these things
and and she's like okay you know you're
like you can you can plead guilty and
you can go with the sentence and
guidelines which is going to be like
she's like I mean it depends she said it
might be whatever 54 years she was but
if they run them you know concurrent or
consecutive depending on which one they
do she said it most likely it ends up
being like 30 years you know it's like
that's not good that's not good so we
kind of go back and forth back and forth
and figure out try and figure out where
I'm look what I'm looking
at now as we go through the whole thing
we end up she ends up with she ends up
saying you
know she knocks off a bunch of stuff
that they're saying I did you know um
enhancements because you'll have a base
level en a base level of let's say uh
level eight you know that should be that
should be maybe a few years but then
they start adding on enhancements you
know um did he what did what he do was
it sophisticated yes okay three levels
for sophisticated means um were there
more than how many victims were there
more than 50 victims yes okay that's six
more levels okay uh did he change the
jurisdiction to evade detection yes
that's four more levels okay did he they
start adding boom boom and when you
start adding up all those
levels plus your criminal history and I
have a big criminal history because I
was already on federal probation and I
committed a new crime on federal
probation so that was another
enhancement and this you know this case
so I'm like a category like category two
or three so they come back and they're
saying I forget it's like 20 well they
don't come back right away but she ends
up saying you're probably looking at 14
years okay that's reasonable that's
reasonable and so she's
saying so we get the when we get the PSI
back we off get what's called a
precentage report they're saying 26
years well they really said 32
years and I argued and we got it down to
26 years and four months that's what it
is it's 316 months that's how they do it
in
months doesn't sting that much I guess
if you say
months yeah so she says to me Millie
sits down with me and she says
listen you got to cooperate and I was
like okay and she said because you're
you're you're guilty you're extremely
guilty she's like you can't go to
trial and she said so you need to
cooperate I was like well what do I get
if I cooperate she the way it works is
you
cooperate and you hope for the best and
I was like are you serious you tell them
everything you know and you hope for the
best and she's like the the what part of
the problem is she said everybody in
Tampa has cooperated Rebecca has
cooperated every everyone across the
board is cooperation there's nobody that
hasn't cooperated by the way when you
say coopera you mean they're an inform
they told they AKA snitched right they
they came in they sat down with their
lawyer and they said this is what he did
he did this he did that they showed him
documents yes yes yes that's my
signature I didn't know what that was I
you know they everything was my fault
they didn't do anything it was all me so
they've all cooperated and they haven't
been charged they've been indicted
they're all named as unnamed
co-conspirators on my indictment so I've
got like 12 people even there's like
probably 20 people that are involved but
there's like 12 of them that are so I've
got all these names you know uh KB DLC y
you know it's like I know who that is
like I know who DW that's Dave Walker I
know who you know I know who these
people are and so there's just a list of
there's like 12 of them you know plus
me uh
so and some of some of them walked in
and said I'm guilty I just want to be
plead guilty the the the girl uh Allison
MH she walked in said I I'm I'm too I'm
tired of waiting for you to come get me
walked in with her lawyer and said I
just want to plead guilty and and they
sentenced her and she went to jail she
got like 36 months or 30
months she called the
prison the she went to the low security
it was a female prison at the time
female Camp called the camp and asked
for if she could come by for a tour
before she went and they went excuse me
she said well I'm going to be there for
about two years so I'd like to come and
is there like a tour I can take because
I like to know where I'm going what it's
going to be like how I should prepare
and they just started laughing they said
there's no tour sweetie we'll give you
the tour when you get
here you gotta love that like she yeah I
mean I thought I was I didn't think I
thought I wasn't uh prepared I mean
there's no tour so uh Becky Becky got 70
months but when I got caught and when I
was sentenced they reduced it to like 30
or no 40 to 40 months they reduced
because she co co cooperated that
term right do you want to say snitch or
well there must be I mean snitch is too
harsh of a word but yeah the red I mean
you're
saying I don't know we can get there
we'll get there all right all
right